I wanted to give you credit for having
one of the coolest things I've ever seen
at a wedding where you had llamas oh
yeah llamas and I actually I wanted to
show I took this photo at your wedding
it has a bow tie and then we had a
female one that had flowers
really yeah here's the speed round you
want to do is oh so I just answer in one
word or you can do they need but yes I
can get about I don't know what these
questions are yeah you don't know um God
did you feel the energy just like James
just vacuumed
it's like Suzy slipped up for Tucker
yeah
great thing yeah thank you I went to the
card oh yeah I never was like just zoned
out it's like their outer space and
we're Sandra Bullock and we got in and
like didn't go up at all her hair didn't
go up and why hadn't she shot her pants
she's just flung around space
let it rip Bullock what if she did well
they're eating like space food so they
like this it's not gonna create that
much to shat I'm assuming you think they
were like ah like we got a lot of volume
in there and maybe she went before it
all happened well just ask one of these
Oh
what we're not this is a speed round Oh
wedding on Teddy what's your favorite
ghost it's on here right oh I didn't
know I honestly I don't know how I have
my favorite ghost probably probably like
my grandma
I think that's good we're gonna stop at
the top Christian she'll everybody
catfishing on the finale of Bob's
Burgers May 18th on Fox thank you